warum gibt es immer noch Schulen in
denen man sein Handy benutzen darf warum
ist es nicht obligatorisch dass man sein
Handy für die gesamte Zeit die man an
der Schule ist abgeben muss so dass man
lernt ja ich komme auch vier bis acht
Stunden ohne Handy am Tag klar warum
gibt es nicht in ganz Deutschland
einfach
Medienkompetenz wir setzen uns die ganze
Zeit Medien aus und lernen nichts
darüber dafür fangen wir ab Klasse 7 an
mit Buchstaben zu rechnen Kurven
Diskussion hieß das und wer da Bock
drauf hat ey Leute macht das gerne zieht
durch aber mir ist danach nie wieder
eine Kurve begegnet mit der ich
diskutieren wollte